after getting everybody's hopes raised
over the weekend with the release of a
surprise teaser the truth behind the
Danny McBride starring Crocodile Dundee
reboot has been discovered and it's all
a lie an investigation conducted by the
Brisbane Times has uncovered that the
movie is nothing more than a viral
marketing stunt for tourism Australia
the movie was initially announced on
Friday in an exclusive report by people
which featured deceptive quotes from
McBride and Paul Hogan the original
movies Mick Dundee that annoyed Hogan
said in the people reveal throughout the
past few years I've been thinking about
how to bring Dundee to a new generation
I'm excited to introduce a new Crocodile
Dundee to the world and look forward to
sharing more news about those involved
very soon Hogan previously served as an
Australian tourism pitchman in 1984 with
a g'day mate campaign which continues to
inform just about every stereotypical
view Americans hold of the land down
under the initial Dundee trailer was met
with skepticism from the start by many
commentators in the entertainment
industry who questioned how a movie with
an IMDB estimated budget of 30 million
dollars and the involvement of such busy
performers as McBride and Chris
Hemsworth could have been made in
absolute secrecy while Hemsworth's
involvement in the movie second teaser
appeared to add some credibility to the
project others noticed a curious fact
that Hemsworth is currently employed as
a tourism Australia ambassador but that
was enough to convince many that the
movie wasn't quite on the level thanks
to the Brisbane times that theory has
now been over proven a last port Dundee
we hardly knew ye everybody pour out a
little Bundaberg for the summer we could
have had good a losers thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
you